was station
ever going to be part of the movie um
for for a second he was going to be in
the open the opening uh
uh montage but but it it didn't make any
sense
um we just brought him back with what uh
with with ken cutty at the end
um just to remind the audience that
um we're missing him sure no i mean you
hear it in the movie station
yeah um uh uh was there a character or
characters from the previous films
that you wanted to include uh but
couldn't uh for some reason
yes george carlin because he died right
well
absolutely um i i worshiped at
george garland's feet i mean i thought
it was just brilliant one of the
most brilliant um and smartest
of the comedians of my era
not to mention as i understand a one a
great human being but you know his
daughter kelly is is
one of the scientists in the uh in the
future um
if you want to find a an easter egg um
oh that's a good easter egg
yeah um the um
no we brought back everybody it was hard
with the wives because
which wives do you cast right you can't
they were recast
um so we just went with what had
happened in
in the second one where they recast the
lives we recast them again
um that was the only thing where you it
didn't make any sense somehow
and it wasn't fair in some ways to
choose once
one over the other and there was also
availability issues so
uh but no i don't think so
uh yeah it didn't make sense given this
story and where we were
so you mentioned a second ago the movie
ends with a post credit scene
of bill and ted older at the end of the
credits um
what was the original post credit scene
gonna be if you had shot it
uh no that was the original that we shot
on location
uh we had with the
there was going to be a scene after
um we leave them on the stage at the end
there was going to be a scene there that
we didn't get we didn't get to shoot
um and instead um
i i mean i i i love the last line of
this movie it's
it's it's a pro was appropriate to this
moment in history
when we're making the movie and it's
even more appropriate now unfortunately
given our situation
um that um you know it's not
it's not it wasn't the song so much is
that everybody played it together
um and that's um that's what that movie
basically ends up being about um
and i and um but that was originally
uh we were the scene was the same it was
the same idea but the scene was
different
um but the the post-credit uh
scene was always meant to be there um
we shot we shot three or four of those
we just improv them we just kept
improving them
got it they're all hysterical
yes that that scene is also a great way
to end it though the way you have it at
the end of the credits um
so one of the other things that i was
curious about is anthony uh kerrigan's
character has sort of been kept under
wraps this entire time
and like to me it's not that big of a
deal as character
what was the motivation from you guys in
the studio to keep his character under
wraps
well i think we didn't want to give away
his uh
transition you know okay
um because it was too much fun it was
it's fun to watch him start out
as this um threatening killer robot and
then
um you know start to transition
uh in into a into a human
so um yeah we just didn't want to it's
like you give every
the danger of all these trailers is uh
that they give away every story point in
a movie right um
so there's no surprise for anybody
anymore and
uh you know i think every filmmaker
fights this
when it comes to selling a movie and
every studio wants to put everything in
there to get everybody into the seats
but
um there's that balancing act and and uh
uh orion was really good at listening to
us and keeping uh trying to keep a
balancing act
of not um you know giving too much away
in that trailer
uh but if you know if i had my druthers
um uh
i'd just have a teaser and leave it at
that well i've had this conversation
with many many directors
um about the marketing of movies and um
i listen i do think it's cool that
there's a character that no one
knows that will you know as you push
play or watch it in the theater
you know you'll see something you had no
idea was coming
yeah that's right i you got to save
something
completely so i would imagine there was
a lot of bands
that uh might have wanted to contribute
how did you guys decide on the
on the soundtrack and ultimately how did
you decide on what song was going to be
the thing that saves the universe
well the second half of that question is
a is a very long answer but
um the first half is was
we we utilized um we had a wonderful
uh uh music supervisor jonathan leahy
who i had worked with um last year on a
television series
uh and um he was just brilliant at this
he kept throwing music at us and we kept
there wasn't that much
room for it but we would open up
we knew there was places where you know
like when the booth is traveling things
like that where we can utilize
um uh songs rather than score
um so we're looking for a balancing act
um
and uh uh some of it came ahead of time
but most of it came in post
most of it was it was was john um
throwing us discoveries um and
there were some phenomenal ones i
thought um
the last one was that um that song they
play at the wedding which i just thought
was
just wildly great um
but um as far as the song that saves the
world uh
yeah i think for seven years i kept
saying we better get this song
and of course uh
john kept trying to get people to
give it a try uh and then uh we didn't
really
hit it um and so i had to shoot it
uh without the song uh when i shot the
movie
but i played back uh
we played back so they could perform
to uh a certain um
beats per minute so that we can repeat
it when we have we we actually built the
song
which we did we kind of frankenstein
together a whole lot of stuff that
that uh john had brought together uh
which i thought worked
i i i love that piece of music i think
it works brilliantly i
i i was terrified we were never going to
get it
um um but i'll i'll admit we played
obligation
on the set that's amazing
113 beats per minute that's amazing look
the fact is that uh thankfully it's not
about the song as much as it is about
everyone coming together
yes that that was the idea and it had to
be a good song but
it's a very daunting thing to put the
best song ever written into a movie
i agree listen i i have to stop there i
could ask you a million other things i'm
just going to say
again congrats on the movie and i wish
you nothing but the best
thank you stephen a real pleasure